so this hilt has all the original parts
that were used on the obi-wan sabre in a
new hope that's right this is the holy
grail of all holy grail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are in the offices of sabre mock this
is a singapore's saber company of course
sorts right yes you guys make sabers
jay as the founder
has
the holy grail that's right so over here
we have a
saber that is made out all the original
found items
that was used to make the ob1 saber from
a new hope so as you know during the
1970s they don't have a huge budget they
can't machine the savers so they they
took a lot of the found objects that
they could find and piece everything
together so
over here this is all the original part
that were used and we managed to track
them down put them all together and form
the ob1 saver
how many
of these type of saber hilts are in
the world so
based on my last 15 20 years of
collection i would say that probably
about less than 10 in the entire world
because the parts are really really
scared and um you don't really find them
very often right now so about 10 in the
world by 10 in the world
like this
what kind of value would this be if you
were to sell this out there what do you
think so the recent auction by one of
the collectors uh it was ranging between
15 to about 25 000 u.s dollars
yeah
wow and that is if you can find one so
even if you have the money you might not
be able to find the parts as well now
let's go through some of the parts
because this is really interesting walk
us through how this hilt was made okay
so uh for the ob1 sabre is actually made
of five of different parts so you can
see people here so i'm going to go with
the bottom all the way to the top sure
in terms of scarcity of parts right okay
so this is actually um a faucet knob
made by the company called the army tech
shank so i believe this if not wrong is
about in the 1960s or 1970s
so if you're looking at now you are in
2022 it's about 50 over years since they
they made this wow so this was probably
plucked out from a hotel or someone's
home so uh this is a faucet knob
actually is the name right there on
so uh and then moving upwards this uh
bottom section here is actually uh taken
from a what they call a booster
uh for a world war two machine gun
so
if you look at uh a flash suppressor
right yeah uh so this is like that heat
sink yeah uh just below the suppressor
to kind of ease out all the heat so this
is like a heat sink and of course in the
middle this is a
middle clamp yeah uh taken out from a
graflex tree cell
um that is basically basically a flash
gun that was used in the 1940s a lot of
all the press uh all the reporters in
bangkok oh right the flash yes you have
the flashlight
stuff yes so you will you will recognize
this uh as part of the saber for the
luke skywalker yep from the new hope so
you will recognize that this is part of
his saber as well okay right over here
is actually uh if you can see there's
seven digits or seven bubbles one two
three four five six seven right so this
is what they call a seven digit x uh
bubble calculator from the company
called etc okay so i can't remember when
this was uh produced
but this is actually that
that magnifier that magnifies the digit
on the calculator itself interesting
over here um i have no idea why they
choose to do it but this too is actually
a
transistor
uh
it's from this brand called makoni yep
so i have no idea why they put it over
here uh but if you look at the screen um
the screen grab or the reference photo
the original prop you will see that the
markings the me and the d80 is actually
on the
reference photo so really yeah so this
is the exact transistor out there
and um moving up yeah this itself is one
of a pretty rare one as well if you look
at this british rifle grenade or they
call it the mk one wow
okay so uh of course it's in it yeah
meaning that uh if you open up this
there's no uh gunpowder anything it's
just a machine part so if you want to
launch a grenade you put this into your
rifle and you blast it off and
apparently this wind vane here is going
to guide your
grenade to the direction of
you know isn't this fascinating this is
absolutely i'm blown away amazing how
they put all this together i have no
idea how they even could think about
putting a rifle grenade inside and of
course we come to the part that is the
but
it's really really scary i believe that
you can only find this right in a uh jet
engine uh by rolls-royce so this is
actually called a derwent or
w and derwent jet engine okay this is
called a balanced pipe i have no idea
what the part is used for in the
rolls-royce but uh
it is part of a jet engine so if you
know ig-88 right the derwent jet engine
is taken out of the ig-88
yes you didn't know that right so so if
you look at ideas some parts of it is so
that that balance part is stuck in there
and they have like eight of them they
have the male and the female version
yeah this is the female version the
correct one and they pluck it out so if
you get a derwin jet engine you can take
out eight of them
so this completes the original found
items that were used to make the
original
saber for obi-wan so this is i mean
obviously you have
vader and skywalker saber all original
parts oh you know possibly so like i
mentioned earlier this is actually a
graph flex a camera flash yeah if you
put this in into the
camera and there's a big flash over here
yeah so that you know when you press the
button and then the in the whole flash
yeah so this is actually part of it okay
uh this is also another flash but by a
brand called mpp stands for micro
precision
product
this flash itself is uh manufactured
much lesser than the graphics so you can
really find this
on ebay from vintage um camera
collectors you can find them but this is
really really hard to find
so um this is like the second holy grail
and um so basically i've got this part
for a couple of years so i think about
last year i sent this part uh to a guy
um his company's name is called iron
destiny so he is a specialist in um
taking all these parts and and get all
the different like the grips and stuff
like that and get all the notches the
dents the scratches
uh he replicates all those
exactly from the reference photos of the
original part but look at all the dings
on the grip as well these were all
that's all like hand done his hand is
supposed to be brand new
try to get one so it's a lot of um a lot
of work to get this uh done by the guys
uh in iron destiny that's the original
yep now this is what you guys make here
that's right which is based basically
almost the exact same thing here yeah so
this one itself uh
um you can see that it is very close to
the um to the original one of course it
doesn't have all the dings and dance of
your sure so this is like a pristine uh
machined version of the replicas okay
yeah yeah this is why but it's still
made of steel as well yeah so the
original part for this tool is actually
made of steel so this tool is also made
of steel right so they are not aluminum
no it feels very weighty i mean very
lady this one is not something that you
would necessarily use for combat or for
it's more for show it is we're going to
talk because you guys do combat sabers
as well right
okay cool so now i i know you got a one
of your associates here who's sort of
like your padawan yeah in a sense so is
our lead designer at stablemark he
designs a lot of the uh saber design he
designs all the chassis
uh some of the different components of
the savers so yeah he's the guy okay
yeah afree come on in man so walk us
through some of the things you do here
okay so uh like jay mentioned i am the
lead designer so when it comes to
designing work it's not just about how
the sabre looks on the outside and how
fantastic it looks yeah but also how
well it runs on the inside
so i've got with me here
one of our newer stuff
wow
so over time we want to try and
continuously uh improve
on how the electronics are held inside
so you know back then it was held by
acrylic or delrin discs but now we have
3d printing 3d printing is such an
amazing technology that we've had for
the past few years yeah
the electronics are held
comfortably and you know and they are
shock proof so these are the things that
i i do on a day-to-day basis and not
just uh the the hardware
i also met with the software so when it
comes to
um you know how a sailor behaves right
with uh the blade attached yes so all
these little fine things like how the
saber ignites how it retracts how the
different you know blaster blocks
activate these are the kind of stuff
that that i
you play with all the time so you're
giving people a very creative option to
sabers out there that's right we're
watching the ob1 trailer the new series
coming out may 27th plug for disney plus
and the saber though is a little bit
different
than the one from a new hope isn't it
walk us through what's the difference
real quick so i think um okay eagle
light fans would probably notice that
the saber that
he's holding is not really from a new
hope so we won't exactly be seeing this
version
you'd probably be
a little more familiar with the uh
version that was released in the revenge
of the sith the the one slight
difference that you'd probably be able
to see
even i think in in they've released a
couple of close-up shops uh shots of
the saber is the emitter cup
now we think we think we believe the
emitter cup is going to be the one
that's
from a new hope ah and of course the
save is gonna be a little weathered yes
okay
but we don't know if he'll get another
saber before the end of the series the
ghost kind of transitions into new hope
so so we're waiting we're waiting yeah
we want to see more first before we get
anything done so for the collectors out
there they're going to be anticipating
this show not just because they want to
watch it but what saber obi-wan is
wielding that's right all right let's go
check out your workshop can you show us
a little bit of that
that's badass right yeah
you know you know to wield this a lot
better than i do
[Music]
this is this is a 100 made in-house by
sabermak so
i can show you a couple of stuff that
i'm working on yeah so what we have here
is a
dark silver flat blade
before assembly so essentially what goes
into your typical
uh premium level blades are your led
strips okay these led strips are the
kinds that you see in your computer yeah
so those rgb strips right
the great thing about these strips are
because they are programmable you get
all these kind of fun effects
you can program them to have blaster
blocks
lock up
the ignition and retraction these are
machine in-house this is 3d printed
designed by ourselves here
the strips go inside we put the vinyl on
and then after that we
secure the pcb yeah and then goes into
testing so
here in sabermak we have different tiers
of sabers that we offer customers right
okay right so we've got
replicas which we call the legacy series
we've got the premium ones which are 100
machine in-house we also have uh a tier
of sabers called kit savers yeah kit
sabers they are affordable ones
customers who are a little tight on the
money yeah but still want to have
something cool sure so what we did with
this one is we took a
a budget sabre yeah and we added our own
flair to it
so
this one's clearly inspired by a
samurais katana yeah so we added a
subaru we added a leather wrap we even
provide a
sheath for customers awesome
okay so it's oh it's very different than
yes i see what you're saying yeah
but
their combat will be okay so you can
really beat these around and it's good
it still has smooth swing
but believe it or not this is a budget
saver
yeah there we go interesting
now you showed us
more of the budget side what's the most
extravagant let's show it to you yeah so
we we also have customers who want
designs that are unique to themselves
right not just on the outside but on the
inside as well so this one that we have
here
is an acid-etched
uh sabre so wow the design is inspired
by
a character from the old republic games
and then the customer wanted
sort of an olive green with a
rust weathering so we made that not so
obvious so we don't want you know the
weather to be so overwhelming yeah but
the customer also requested
a metal 3d printed uh chassis cover wow
jeez
that's beautiful it's amazing
that is beautiful
we i'm afraid to ask what the price
would be on something like that
um it's up there right
it's up there but it's not four digits
four digits it's four digits four digits
okay this one is going to be a part of
our premium saber
so this one is a new
uh design that we came up with last year
when you're holding this
it's beautifully made
it feels very well balanced
it's kind of i mean was it stainless
steel or aluminum this is aluminum yeah
it's lightweight but i mean just the
craftsmanship just the amount of detail
is awesome you take a look there yeah i
see that
we've got a laser cut air balloon wow
shell
uh which are responsibly sourced yeah of
course of course yeah
and uh
inside we have a kyber crystal that's
right so this one's a prototype of the
one that we're going to be putting into
uh production
and it'll light up it as well it does
whoa yeah so the chamber was in metal
this one's just a prototype print and
we've got an oled in the back as well oh
[ __ ] that's badass
so how do you charge this or you just
change the battery so
batteries are removable okay
let's get a battery charger yeah pull
the battery out
and then put them into a battery charger
okay they run on 18650 batteries yeah uh
they should typically last between 45 to
an hour okay uh if you put the saber on
max settings okay yeah well that's
awesome all right
afree thank you sir
whoa
whoa do that again do it again what is
it it boots up
wow
why is he really responsive that's
amazing you'll see these uh soon
hopefully
maybe the end of the year okay all right
you know we haven't seen yet we just saw
a little bit of the dark saber do you
have an actual normal saber blade like a
round one we do
whoa
so you have
the ignition and retraction effects
you've also got blaster blocks
plate lock up
you can actually even move
and lock up
as you tilt the saver
because you know you want your duals to
be dynamic right so if i'm blocking that
way and then you know
we've got another blade coming up oh
that's nice yeah so these are what
uh the black to lapse crystal focus x
soundboard it's capable of and these
blades are combat ready blades combat
ready bleeds wow
it's so responsive it is so responsive
you know
wow
thank you thank you thank you all right
we're going to check out see what jay's
doing downstairs
see the manufacturing process they're
going to come back and take a look at
some of you got the display as well all
right all right thanks auf we appreciate
it man thank you
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
so this is the lathe right here but
where what are the machines you have
here in the shop right so we also have a
milling machine okay um over there okay
and uh we have the two laser machine one
for cutting for larger pieces the other
one for engraving so how much hours how
many hours do you spend here a day uh
anywhere from 12 to 15 hours
cutting cutting i mean we are going by
batches right wow we are doing a batch
of stuff we here for all week 15 12 to
15 hours but when we are not doing
machining then we are going we are
upstairs doing an assembly all right jay
well thank you so much for this and uh
we'll go upstairs and see some of the
sabers that you guys make yep and so
try some of them out as well you should
let's do it all right all right jay
thank you so much for showing this uh my
pleasure man yeah this has been a lot of
fun a lot of i mean just the knowledge
here yes pretty overwhelming right
actually it's pretty many details and
stuff there's a lot of details and look
at all these sabers that you guys sell
the legacy
all the way to some of the inspired
versions right
absolutely awesome and this piece is
very interesting yes so this is a work
in progress it's what we call the melt
so basically it simulates let's say if
you would put disable it through a meta
door yeah it starts to melt okay so
that's how the effect of the uh saber is
going to look like
oh wow yeah so of course this is
actually a magnet so if if you have a
fridge or a cabinet that's made of metal
you put it in it kind of simulates that
that whole melt loop it looks a lot
better during night time as well that's
very cool yeah so that is a work in
progress but uh it's a it's one of our
original designer designs i don't think
anyone else is doing this yeah yeah that
is wicked all right jay thanks for that
i've got the high ground saber in my
hand that's right which is very
reminiscent of something that may be
coming out at the end of this month and
on this one yes yep and you've got your
own and i have one this is a flat blade
let me turn it on let's turn it on
right oh wow
hey
all right guys that wraps it up for us
right now we're gonna saber duel like
this video subscribe to the channel
sabermock.com until the next one take
care
[Music]